what is up guys my name is the channel
and welcome to Episode seven of three
game programming in Java
now promised last time we do an FPS
counter and that is what we're going to
do today but first of all I just want to
come in here and sort of fix this up a
bit because um because width and height
um and title as well are static
variables that means that they don't
need an object to be used so when I
created this object that was sort of
unnecessary what we could have done is
simply um you know simply just use it
like that so if capital D for display
and that would be referring directly to
do this to the display class so static
variables do not need to be initialized
I'm sorry another thing is we actually
have it in a simpler way is because
we've sort of we've we've set this equal
to to render and stuff and um an to
screen and when we go screen we
initialize it with and hide it would
also work if we just simply put height
as in well as in these variables because
that that would also work and then here
you know same thing with and that uh
that should work as well and yep it does
okay so without further ado and we can
remove this import I'm going to get to
the FPS counter okay so basically what
an FPS counter does is it's supposed to
measure basically the amount of frames
that it's sort of processed and the
amount of times its updated the screen
and the way that I'm that I'm going to
do this is it's pretty it's pretty
simple it's pretty much the same is you
like it's pretty much the same for all
applications we need to make a few few
into integers and doubles and even along
they'll be along in there as well new
data type which I'll talk about in a
minute I want to make an integer called
frames and this is best going to be the
amount of frames and its rendered at the
moment it's not actually running because
as you can see this is before the while
loop running
so we're going to add to zero I'm also
going to make a double called
unprocessed seconds and that's going to
basically be you know the amount of
seconds that we haven't actually
processed yet that haven't actually been
recorded okay and we're going to make a
long called previous time we'll call
previous time because we'll be referring
to it from here and we'll set that equal
to system nano time and I'll talk about
that it right now along is a new
variable type that we haven't talked
about basically a long is like an
integer except it its 64-bit data type
and it can store a lot more numbers in
integer I think integers like from -
like 3.5 billion to positive 3.5 billion
this is like nine trillion it's like -
nine trillion - positive nine trillion
so Long's are really really big and we
want that and systems of nano time is a
new thing in java 1.6 I don't know if
it's new in Java 1.6 but it's something
that's been it's it's only been
introduced to jail recently and it's the
most it's the app it's the most precise
available system timer because it
measures it in nanoseconds and it's
really really precise so it measures the
CPU cycles as accurately as possible
before you know you use current time in
milliseconds ok and then we'll also make
when is winning a sort of translate this
stuff into seconds
so there are so we're going to go ahead
and name the seconds per tick and tick
is going to be you know sort of every
time it renders every time it ticks and
we'll set that equal to one divided by
sixty point zero because we want to be
really precise and finally take count
we're going to set to zero and I'm also
going to make a billing actually called
ticked and I'm going to set that equal
to false so it after it's sort of ticked
we'll set that equal to true okay so and
running let's delete this for now
because I want to sort of put that into
a different thing so now we're in the
while loop so we sort of need
update I guess some of these things
first thing I want to do is create a
long called current time and this is
basically going to be the system done a
no time within this loop I'm also going
to make make a long called past time and
we'll set that equal to current time
which is this thing current time and
it's going to be minus our previous time
so it's basically going to work out the
difference of of this and this okay and
then I'm just going to go ahead and go
and set previous time equal to current
time and I've sort of backslash Devon
arisen and also unprocessed seconds I'm
going to add to it every time it
completes this loop I'm going to add to
it past time divided by 1 billion which
is one two three four five six seven
eight nine zeros point zero um okay
and we're also going to make another
while loop here and we're going to go
ahead and go while unprocessed seconds
is greater than seconds per tick then
basically we want to tick and of course
ticker is referring to this which we
haven't set up yet we'll do probably get
onto that next time not sure and also
we're going to subtract seconds per tick
from unprocessed seconds seconds per
tick because yeah so basically every
time it's completing the loop it's going
to subtract seconds per seconds per tick
from unprocessed seconds and we're going
to set it to equal true and we're going
to add one add one to the tick count
value and also we're going to say if
tick count
has a remainder of 60 as a reminder of
60 and it's equal to zero then we're
going to simply system dot out dot print
line go ahead and print the frames the
frames are followed by fps and also you
know we'll also have to add one thousand
to previous time and then again you know
it's at the frames to zero again and
that should be it
oh we need a render that's right so
that's the good thing about using like
an IDE and stuff it helps it says you
know we haven't used this called this
thing yet which is really important
because it's not going to not going to
work unless we render so we're going to
go ahead and say if tacticals true then
you know render and add 1-2 frames and
we'll render it hang a minute and we'll
we'll render again because we need to
because even while it's not take 20 to
render and we'll also add 1-2 frames
okay so that's that's the FPS counter I
don't know if that will work let's test
it out okay let's sort of working
hmm okay it's set it's saying that we're
getting 24 frames per second but I don't
think that's correct because it feels
like we're getting a lot more okay let's
go into let's actually test this out
real quick by going to Randall and we'll
debug this and this is block line in the
middle of my screen okay well and we'll
go to screen and we will increase this
and also if it falls yeah okay as you
can see you can see that the changes
that it makes is running at four frames
per second now and there is running it
twelve fifty thirty okay yeah it's
better that's smooth okay yeah yes I was
working um I don't know it feels yeah it
is it is sort of lagging I guess yeah
that's correct
okay the a path counter is is a go Reese
working perfectly so yeah so I can
compare sorted this how it's sort of a
bit laggy it's running at 24 frames per
second at the moment and if I go into
screen and I change this to you know as
I said you know I'll spin times before
already but at 50 or 500 not 500 if I
change that to 50 and then I times this
by 8 so double what it was then you can
see how that you can see how that looks
the same but it's suddenly running it
like that almost double the frame rate
so yeah so that's that's sort of I guess
builds onto our performance thing and
that is frames per second so I think
that that that's it um yeah well it's
working so it's fine
okay so yeah that's that's how you make
an FPS counter that's how you add it to
your game it's very important um we
could print it actually onto the
graphics screen but it's going to be
quite difficult to do that not difficult
but it's going to be sort of awkward to
do that
of the fact that you know we can't just
do it using java's graphics we'll have
to actually you know use use buffers and
stuff like that so we're not going to do
that for now but we might add that later
once we actually get like a room maybe
to walk around it and stuff like that
okay so that's it
I hope you guys enjoy the tutorial if
you liked it hit the like button and
yeah I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
[Music]